hi everyone and welcome to this special
edition of hannity fighting the radical
left
i'm tammy bruce in for sean and tonight
with july 4th around the corner
millions of americans are gearing up to
celebrate the greatest country
on planet earth but hold onto your seats
because the biden administration has a
major announcement
according to the white house the price
of a july 4th cookout
has decreased by an incredible 16 cents
forget about the 50 increase in gas
prices or the four percent rise in
housing
or the 21 surge in used cars or the 124
percent increase in lumber
thanks to joe biden you just saved 16
cents
on your cookout unless you're having hot
dogs the price of a hot dog is now
at a 10-year high but jen sake never
lets the truth get in the way of a good
narrative
take a look subject the official white
house account tweeted yesterday
the cost of a fourth of july cookout is
down 16 cents
from last year 16 cents
there has been a reduction in some of
the costs of key components of the
fourth of july
fourth of july barbecue that was what
the tweet was noting so does the white
house think
that 16 cents off a barbecue has more of
an impact on people's lives
than gas being a dollar more this time
at this point i would say if you don't
like hot dogs you may not care of the
reduction of costs
you don't have
so disconnected while jen saki spins in
circles her boss joe biden
is flat out refusing to answer questions
because it's friday
and we're heading into a holiday weekend
take a look
i'm not going to answer any more a quick
question in afghanistan look at
this fourth of july i'm concerned that
you guys are asking me questions that
i'll answer
next week but on this the holiday
weekend i'm going to celebrate it
there's great things happening
economy's growing faster than any time
in 40 years we've got a record number of
new jobs covades are down 90
wages are up faster than any time in 15
years
we're bringing out bringing our troops
home we have all across america people
are going to ball games and
doing good things this is a good i'll be
an ally answer all your negative
questions not negative you're a
legitimate question
come on man no doubt joe biden is primed
and ready for some rest and relaxation
but
make no mistake his radical base is hard
at work and the next item on their
agenda
court packing and if they get their way
the integrity of the us supreme court
will in fact be ruined forever joining
me now with more is former acting
director of national intelligence rick
grinnell
along with former trump white house
chief of staff reince priebus
thank you guys for coming on here i
appreciate it reince
i i have to say that when it comes to
the job of being commander in chief
it i thought it was 24 7 especially with
all kinds of things going on in the
world
what is your take on this this attitude
from joe biden of
i don't want to talk about afghanistan
it's the fourth of july
is is that a normal and and even safe
approach for the president
uh no not at all tammy and happy fourth
to you
and to rick uh not at all i mean it's
obviously a 24 7
operation but it's also something that
is very serious and when someone has a
question about afghanistan and troops
that are leaving
air bases that have been occupied with
american airmen
and soldiers and marines um for the past
two decades
it's something that the president needs
to answer and but he doesn't and the
media
gives them a pass but i think it would
be actually more fun if we played the 16
cents game and see how many things we
could actually
buy with 16 cents like maybe
a button uh a a jolly rancher perhaps
not even that 16 cents
right 16 cents can buy you 4
of a gallon of gas so um
totally out of touch while cops are
getting shut
shot up olympic athletes are turning
their back on the flag
and 180 000 people are pouring over the
border
every month they're going to be in for a
reckoning
very very soon in this country what's
frightening
rick it's and you've both of you have
been right next to the seat of power
there
is that with that 16 cent that you know
meme
on uh on social media it does it
invites mockery and ridicule it kind of
signifies that whoever's making this
decision
is completely disconnected and they
think so little of us that they think
we're going to get excited about 16
cents
16 cents won't get you on the other side
of the washington post
paywall where all of the newsrooms in
washington d.c
across the political spectrum are
celebrating the 16 cents and so
what happens in washington dc is is that
they read each other they retweet each
other they recycle each other's news
and then they go into the newsroom and
they say wow this is such a popular
story
of saving 16 cents but they never really
realize
is that they're they're literally
retweeting and talking
amongst themselves this is the problem
of washington
it's so insular i'm here in california
people mock this story they know that
when they drive to the grocery store
they just blew through way more money
than 16
cents and there's a whole list of things
that are more expensive and so
only in washington dc does this type of
narrative work and joe biden will keep
ignoring
questions about foreign policy because
he gets to the media will allow him to
when in washington dc but when you talk
to regular people
they're laughing well it's another we
know it's a disconnection but
rights it really is when we're dealing
with them thinking that 16 cents would
rock our world it's the same as with
during the pandemic
when what was also going to rock our
world was 1200 bucks
which maybe would last a week or pay a
couple of bills
or is going to get you through maybe two
weeks
uh this is where americans are realizing
that
they have no idea what is happening in
our lives
in our cities because as bricks noted of
the insular dynamic
or do you think it's possible they
genuinely simply do not care at this
point what's happening to us
uh no i think they're totally out of
touch just as you
and rick just talked about i think
they've totally misread
the american people they think the
american people are stupid that we would
actually be excited about 16 cents but
but they misread the american people on
cops they misread the
american people on the border they
misread the american people in critical
race
on critical race theory and you know in
corporate america dove in with them
but the the regular folks out there
looking around saying
what's going on here in this country in
just six short months
that we're losing not just the economy
in in this country
we're losing the american culture and
what makes the fabric of this
country great and so they missed the
boat in the 16th sense while it is funny
just shows you kind of how backwards
they have
their read on the american people you
know and rick we are here we are at
independence day
um we know that there's going to be no
fireworks right at mount
rushmore uh you know there's some
punishment going on there
uh there's fireworks though of course
across the country uh
this is a time to celebrate and we've
seen
with olympic athletes etc condemnations
of the flag
of america itself is this something that
you think is really embedded in the
democrat party itself
because i'm thinking these are fringe
actors who get a lot of attention and
are elevated
through the system itself that it's
perhaps not something that is infecting
america as a whole
look i think it's a little bit of both
i've been very worried over the last
year that we have too many americans
that are just falling prey to government
directives
that's not what america is about we
we're not supposed to be told
uh to to you know stay in our homes and
and lock our doors and not go out
uh look the the warnings about health
uh practices and covid they're all good
but they're warnings they shouldn't be
mandates i hope the american people
start standing up and pushing back
the country that allows the government
to dictate our our behavior
is the country that falls prey to
totalitarianism and fascism pretty fast
and i'm really worried that we don't
have enough americans
recognizing what the government is
trying to do washington dc as reigns
says corporate america
the media they're all in on this we've
got to push back
and people need to speak up and they
need to be
supported when others speak up so
you know go to facebook go to social
media talk this this weekend when you're
celebrating your freedoms and your
independence
and speak out and don't be afraid ryan
so i'm going to give you the last word
here a few
last thoughts in about the 10 20 seconds
about where you think on this
independence day
where we're headed if americans are
going to finally have had enough
well i think we're heading um if not
in 2022 maybe post 2022
we are headed for a steel cage match
politically in this country
a lot of it's going to do with cultural
decisions that have been made
the economy is going to be the
inflation's going to be hitting the roof
but it's going to be
really this is going to be a call to
question moment
for the american people great point
great way to put it indeed and something
that we
are ready for we're the generation that
was born for this
and washington dc should wake up just a
tad uh thank you gentlemen for joining
me tonight i appreciate it hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else